معنا في المتابعه من مستشفى ناصر في خان
يونس مراسل الجزيره وائل الدحدوح اهلا بك
وائل اذا ارتفاع لعدد الشهداء في ظل قصف
اسرائيلي مستمر على خان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يونس هذا صحيح واخر القصف او اخر الغارات
الاسرائيليه تلك التي استهدفت منطقه محيط
الاوروبي المستشفى الاوروبي الى الجنوب
الشرقي من محافظه خانيونس هذه الغاره
استهدفت مواطنين فلسطينيين في تلك المنطقه
الامر الذي ادى الى استشا احد المواطنين
واصابه اخرين بجروح حسب المصادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه التي قالت بانه تم انتشال
المجموعه التي سقطت بين شهيد وجريح الى
المستشفى الاوروبي بالفعل
وكانت بعدها بلحظات او بدقائق غاره اخرى
استهدفت مجموعه اخرى من المواطنين في
منطقه الفخاري ايضا الى الجنوب الشرقي من
محافظه خانيونس الامر الذي ادى الى
استشهاد فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين بجروح حسب
المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه في كلتا
الغارتين
استهدفتا او نفذتا من خلال طا الطائرات
المسيره الاسرائيليه وهو الامر الذي يؤشر
بما لا يدع مجالا للشك
تكثيف قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لاستخدام
الطائرات المسيره خلال الاونه الاخيره
تحديدا خلال الايام الثلاثه الاخيره سواء
في منطقه خانيونس او في رفح او حتى في
مناطق الوسطى من قطاع غزه الامر الذي يشير
الى ان هذه الغارات تستهدف اصطياد
المقاومين او النشطاء او حتى المواطنين
الذين يحاولون الوصول الى منازلهم في
مناطق تعتبر نائيه نسبيا وكذلك الامر ل
يعني يعني الاهداف المتحركه من قبيل
المركبات الدراجات الناريه والهوائيه حتى
من يسير على الاقدام بكل الاحوال ي اليوم
كان كانت محافظه خان يونس مسرحا لسلسله من
الغارات الاسرائيليه كما هو في كل يوم
الامر الذي ادى في اجمال هذه الغارات الى
سقوط نحو 30 شهيدا وبالتاكيد حسب المصادر
الطبيه الفلسطينيه هناك عدد من الشهداء لا
يستطيع احد الوصول اليهم او انتشالهم
باعتبار ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تمنع
سيارات الاسعاف وترفض حتى التنسيق من خلال
الصليب الاحمر للوصول الى هؤلاء باعتبارها
مناطق ساخنه او مناطق اشتباك او حتى مناطق
نائيه لا يوجد فيها اشتباكات لكن قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ترفض ادخال سيارات
الاسعاف لانتشال جثامين الشهداء بكل
الاحوال المنطقه الوسطى من قطاع غزه كانت
هي الاخرى اليوم عرضه لسلسله من الغارات
الاسرائيليه وعمليات القصف المدفعي التي
ما زالت مستمره في هذه المنطقه وائل
الدحدوح من خان يونس شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه الايضاحات